bonjour à tous
aujourd'hui on va parler du relativisme
depuis que j'ai chen je n'ai jamais
vraiment parlé du relativisme en tout
cas par an détails
et c'est évidemment une lacune une
lacune que je me devais de corriger
parce que le relativisme est une
doctrine très ancienne
c'est une doctrine qui datent de
l'antiquité
mais c'est surtout une doctrine qui
traverse les âges
qui traverse les siècles et les
continents
et qui existe toujours à notre époque
parmi vous il ya peut-être des
relativistes
sans doute même en tout cas des
relativistes qui s'ignore
comme il y a des stoïciens qui
s'ignorent ou comme il y a des spinosi 1
qui s'ignore
et mon travail aujourd'hui ça va être de
dresser le portrait robot du relativiste
ça va être d'expliquer en quoi consiste
cette vision du monde
et de montrer que le relativisme n'est
pas seulement une attitude
une attitude de détachement vis-à-vis du
monde
mais que c'est bel et bien une doctrine
et que cette doctrine repose sur une
réflexion très riche qui mérite qu'on
s'y arrête
alors déjà commencé expliquer ce qu'on
entend par relativisme pour être sûr
qu'on parle bien de la même chose
le relativisme c'est le fait de
considérer que les valeurs partagées au
sein d'une société
les valeurs morales principalement mais
même les valeurs sociales ou esthétique
que toutes ces valeurs dans lesquelles
nous croyons sont propres à certaines
sociétés mais pas à d'autres
autrement dit que les valeurs dans
lesquelles nous croyons ne sont pas des
absolus qu'elles ne sont pas universels
mais qu'elles sont propres à des
cultures et donc à ce titre aucune
valeur ne peut être considérée comme
supérieure à une autre
je vais évidemment donner des exemples
on va faire en sorte de rendre ça qu'on
crée mais retenez déjà cette idée que le
relativisme comme son nom l'indiqué
c'est l'idée que tout est relatif
est relatif ça veut dire relier
relié à une culture relié à une époque
un contexte
le relativisme
c'est le fait être conscient que nous
avons les idées de notre condition socio
culturel
que nous avons les idées de notre
situation historique et géographique
et donc on ne peut pas
absolutiser nos idées ou nos valeurs
parce qu'en réalité nos idées et nos
valeurs n'ont de sens que pour autant
que nous vivons dans une société qui les
admet
en juge en fonction de notre référentiel
culturel
et donc si on change le référentiel
on change les idées
on change les opinions on change les
valeurs on change la façon de voir le
monde
et donc posé la question du relativisme
s'est posé la question
de l' influence du social et du culturel
sur la pensée individuelle
c'est poser la question du
conditionnement culturel
du conditionnement de notre rapport au
monde
et c'est se demander si tout bien
considérer toutes les idées ne se
vaudrait pas
c'est se demander en quoi nos valeurs en
quoi nos idées
seraient les bonnes
poser la question du relativisme s'est
posé la question
de la relativité de nos jugements
c'est à dire du fait que nos jugements
sont relatifs à une situation
est donc ils ne sont jamais absolu
nos jugements ne sont jamais détachés de
leur contexte d'émergence
et c'est là dessus on va se pencher
aujourd'hui
alors j'avais dit que je prendrais des
exemples des exemples de valeur relative
d'idées relative pour montrer justement
en quoi elles sont relatives est ce que
ça signifie
alors on va prendre un cas qui est le
cas de la peine de mort
en france la peine de mort n'a plus
cours
elle a été abolie en 1981 c'était sous
la présidence de françois mitterrand
et quarante ans plus tard on peut dire
que la société française n'a plus tout à
fait la même opinion concernant la peine
de mort
alors en l'occurrence il se trouve que
la peine de mort c'est un sujet qui
continue de diviser l'opinion en france
il ya des raisons pour ça on en parlera
mais globalement à partir du moment où
la peine de mort a été abolie
l'opinion sur la peine de mort a changé
elle a commencé à évoluer
elle a commencé à évoluer parce qu'on
n'a pas le même regard sur une chose
selon que cette chose est en vigueur ou
n'est pas en vigueur
dans une société où la peine de mort est
en vigueur
elle est de fait considérée comme
normale
ce qui est normal c'est ce qui
correspond à la norme
normal c'est qui celui-là normes
or une pratique est d'autant plus normal
qu'elle est répandu
une pratique se normalise à mesure
qu'elle se répand
donc l'opinion qu'on a sur une pratique
ou sur une croyance elle dépend
directement de notre immersion dans ses
pratiques et dans ses croyances
ça ne veut pas dire qu'on est tous des
automates qui se contentent de
reproduire les opinions majoritaires
mais ça veut dire que notre
positionnement vis-à-vis du monde dépend
de notre position dans ce monde
on se positionne idéologiquement se
positionne moralement intellectuellement
à partir de notre position c'est à dire
de notre enracinement dans un contexte
et c'est ça qui fait qu'il n'est pas du
tout absurde de parler par exemple d'une
mentalité bourgeoise
ni même d'une mentalité populaire
parce qu'on a la mentalité de ses
habitudes
on a le logos de son ethos
ce que bourdieu appelait des habitudes
une habitude c'est ce dans quoi on
habite
et par ricochet c'est ce qui nous habite
ou ceux qui nous habille
les habitudes sont les habits de notre
mentalité
donc tout ça pour dire je n'oublie pas
où j'en étais que être contre la peine
de mort dans un pays qui a aboli la
peine de mort
c'est tout aussi normal que d'être pour
la peine de mort dans un pays qui
pratiquent la peine de mort
parce que ça a une influence
et je disais tout à l'heure que
l'opinion continue d'être divisés sur ce
sujet en france
là encore le contexte
entre 2011 et 2012 on est passé de 35% à
45% d'opinions favorables à la peine de
mort
or qu'est-ce qu'il ya eu entre les deux
il y a eu les attentats de toulouse
la première vague d'attentats de grande
ampleur
or il est évident qu'être pour la peine
de mort pour des assassins d'enfants
ça n'a pas tout à fait la même
signification
qu'être pour la peine de mort tout court
ce n'est pas le même contexte
le contexte
c'est ce qui fait que les romains
pratiquer la condamnation à mort en
mettant les condamnés à mort dans des
costumes en paille auxquels ils
mettaient le feu
il en profitait pour faire une fête
joindre l'utile à l'agréable
parce que dans la sont des romains
condamné à mort un criminel
ce n'était pas violer les droits de
l'homme
c'était
rendre la justice
[Musique]
pour les romains jeter les criminels du
haut d'une falaise
ce n'était pas cruel et inhumain
ça allait de soi
et c'était aussi respectable que de se
battre pour l'abolition de la peine de
mort au 20e siècle
parce qu'entre temps les pratiques ont
changé
parce qu'entre temps les moeurs se sont
adoucies
et l'adoucissement prélude à
l'assouplissement
donc si on pose la question qui avait
raison des romains ou des modernes la
réponse est ça dépend
ça dépend de votre position
si vous vivez dans un monde dans lequel
l'un des principes fondateurs et le
caractère sacré de la vie humaine vous
n'aurez pas la même opinion que si vous
vivez dans un monde qui différencie ceux
dont la vie est sacrée et ceux dont la
vie ne l'est pas
donc qui a raison et ben saad votre
référentiel
ça dépend du paradigme dans lequel vous
vous placez
et bien c'est ça le relativisme
c'est l'idée que selon context
tous les points de vue peuvent se
défendre
c'est l'idée qu'il n'ya pas un point de
vue au dessus des autres
parce que le propre d'un point de vue
c'est toujours de se placer au dessus
des autres on
s'est toujours de prétendre à la hauteur
de vue
un point de vue se vit toujours comme
une vérité
il se vit comme un absolu
forcément puisque nous sommes notre
point de vue
notre point de vue est donc un absolu
notre absolue
et bien le relativisme c'est comprendre
que toute personne
a de bonnes raisons de penser ce qu'elle
pense
c'est comprendre que toute culture ou
que toute société a les valeurs de ses
habitudes
ah les idées de ses habitudes
et qu'en définitive
il n'y a pas de hiérarchie à établir
parce qu'une hiérarchie s'établit
toujours sur nos propres critères
jugés notre mentalité supérieur à la
mentalité d'autrui
ces juges et la mentalité d'autrui à
partir de notre mentalité à nous
ses juges et les critères d'autrui à
partir de nos propres critères
donc c'est mettre la réponse dans la
question
ce que nous dit le relativisme sait qu
on aura beau avoir les meilleurs
arguments pour défendre les idées qui
sont les nôtres et les valeurs qui sont
les nôtres
ce ne seront jamais que des arguments à
partir de notre point de vue
et un point de vue n'est qu'un point de
vue
un point de vue légal un point de vue
dont vous et il ya dans le relativisme
un refus la hiérarchie
il y à une horizontale isation du vrai
qu'est ce que je veux dire par là
je veux dire que d'apprendre l'activiste
il n'y a pas de vérité
d'un point de vue relativiste il n'y a
pas de bien
pas de bien au sens de bien absolu
il n'y a pas de sow lui
il n'y a que des biens relatif
relatif un point de vue
relatif un contexte
pour reprendre le vocabulaire
platonicien il n'y a pas de bien en soit
le bien en soi pour les relativistes
c'est un délire
c'est passons
le bian soit le vrai universelle la
justice transcendante tout ça c'est de
la projection
c'est la projection du point de vue en
tant qu il cherche naturellement as
absolutiser
as absolutiser c'est-à-dire à
s'universaliser
à se croire universel
parce que quand on croit à quelque chose
on croit simultanément que ce en quoi on
croit est vrai
on ne croit pas en quelque chose qu'on
estime fo
on croit toujours en quelque chose qu'on
estime vrai
et parce qu'on estime vrai on oublie que
c'est notre estimation qui la rend vrai
la vérité est une animation subjective
du vrai
et donc le relativisme
c'est l'idée qu'il faut reconnaître que
tout ce en quoi on croit
provient d'une estimation
d'une estimation à partir d'un point de
vue
notre point de vue
et quart pour tu ne peux jamais scheer
de sa propre partialité
un point de vue peut s'imaginer qu'ils
s'émancipent de lui-même
qu'il transcende ses propres frontières
mais à moins d'avoir atteint le nirvana
on est tous dépendants de notre
subjectivité
et l'objectivité qu'on imagine pouvoir
atteindre
c'est l'objectivité tels que la perçois
notre subjectivité
ça c'est ce que quand tu as vraiment été
le premier à mettre en avant à savoir
les limites de la subjectivité
les limites de la subjectivité les
limites de la raison et de la
sensibilité individuelle
parce que l'être humain n'est pas un
être mission
parce que l'être humain est calibré sur
le plan cognitif pour percevoir le monde
de manière réduite
on ne peut pas voir plus de trois phases
du dea en même temps
on ne peut pas voir en deçà des
infrarouges et au delà des ultraviolets
il y a un spectre de visibilité qui
montre bien la limitation structurelles
de notre point de vue
comprenez ce que ça veut dire
ça veut dire que notre
sur le monde et toujours fragmenté
nous sommes un fragment de conscience
qui a affaire au monde et notre savoir
n'est que la reconstruction plus ou
moins cohérente de tous nos points de
vue
or cette idée l'idée d'horizontal
isation du vrai
l'idée de la subjectivité radical de
tous nos jugements
c'est l'idée fondatrice du relativisme
tout est relatif ça veut dire tout
dépend du point de vue
tout est vrai pour celui qui le vit
tout est juste pour celui qu'il estime
ainsi
parce que
allemand
il n'y a aucune raison d'accorder un
statut privilégié un point de vue plutôt
qu'un autre
le principal représentant du relativisme
dans l'antiquité c'était protagoras
alors protagoras si vous vous renseigner
sur lui vous verrez qu'il est affublé de
l'étiquette de sophistes
alors un sophiste de nos jours c'est un
usurpateur intellectuelle
c'est un beau parleur
quelqu'un qui tord la vérité par des
procédés rhétoriques fallacieux
mais à l'époque un sophiste c'était un
professeur
c'était un professeur qui détenait un
savoir
la seule différence avec les professeurs
disons classique c'est que le sophiste
avait la faculté de professer un savoir
autant que le savoir opposé
en général un professeur par exemple un
professeur d'histoire il va vous donner
une seule version de l'histoire
il ne va pas vous dire napoléon a
remporté la bataille d'austerlitz en
1805 mais en même temps il ne l'a pas
remporté
non
on trouverait à bairon
on trouverait sabet parce que deux
choses contradictoires entre elles ne
peuvent pas être vrai en même temps
et bien pour les sophistes et pour les
relativistes en général
c'est pas un problème
c'est pas un problème parce qu'à partir
du moment où on considère que tout est
une question de point de vue
et bien la bataille d'austerlitz c'est
une question produits
après tout il ya bien des personnes qui
estiment qu'il ya un roi de france
actuellement
je ne parle pas du président de la
république
je parle d'un vrai roi
le descendant des capétiens qui
s'appelle louis de bourbon louis 20 eh
bien il ya un courant monarchiste qu'on
appelle les légitimistes et qui
considèrent louis 20 comme l'actuel roi
de france
et dans leur paradigme dans leur
référentiel idéologique
ça a du sens
ça même bien plus de sens à leurs yeux
qu'un président élu par le peuple
parce que dans leur vision du monde il y
a un rang à la naissance il y a un sens
royal et donc leur valeur et leur idée
découle de ce postulat initial
leur opinion découle de leur référentiel
le référentiel c'est l'univers mental et
sensorielle à partir duquel on construit
nos jugements
donc un sophiste c'est quelqu'un qui va
adapter son référentiel au point de vue
qu'il cherche à défendre
et comme il est payé pour défendre un
point de vue comme son métier c'est
d'incarner un point de vue comme le font
les comédiens
il ne s'embarrasse pas de questions
aussi abstraite que la vérité
le sophiste c'est celui qui a intégré la
relativité des opinions et qui se sert
de cette relativité des opinions pour
défendre le point de vue pour lequel on
leur a payé
le sophiste c'est le relativiste en
action
parce que c'est le relativiste qui a
compris que si tout est relatif la
morale aussi est relative
et donc se faire payer pour défendre un
point de vue le lundi et le point de vue
opposés le mardi c'est ni bien ni mal
c'est une point de vue
pour les relativistes tout est une
question de point de vue
et ce qui agace et socrates ce n'est pas
seulement le fait que les sophistes
étaient payés pour leur enseignement
parce qu'après tout socrates ne se
faisait pas payer officiellement mais il
vivait aux crochets de ses amis
donc si on veut aller par là pas sûr que
socrate soit le mieux placé
mais surtout ce qui révolte et socrates
s'était que les sophistes parleurs
relativisme par leur capacité à défendre
un point de vue autant que le point de
vue opposés ce qu'ils enseignaient
c'est le nihilisme
c'est à dire la version politique du
relativisme
le fait de ne croire en rien
fait de rejeter tout ce qui était
d'ablis
et donc par conséquent
de renoncer à la vérité
socrates c'est qu'il y avait une vérité
il ne pensait pas que tout est une
affaire de point de vue
et qu'il y avait bien une transcendance
des idées une transcendance du vrai et
du bien
et donc automatiquement il considérait
le relativiste et notamment les
sophistes comme des corrupteurs
les corrupteurs du vrai des corrupteurs
du juste les corrupteurs du bo
est donc là vous le relativisme
c'est une vision qui est en fait le
prolongement de la manière dont on
envisage le concept de vérité
si on considère que la vérité est unique
c'est à dire que là irrité n'est pas
seulement une affaire de point de vue
mais qu'elle transcende les points de
vue
quel est au delà des points de vue
si vous considérez que la vérité est
unique c'est à dire que la vérité et pas
seulement une affaire de point de vue
mais qu'elle transcende les points de
vue qu'elle est au delà des points de
vue
alors vous n'êtes pas relativiste
si on r vous pensez qu'il n'y a pas de
vérité unique et absolue
qu'il n'y a pas un bien un vrai injuste
mais que tout ça est lié à la
subjectivité
et qu'on ne peut pas sortir de cette
alors vous êtes relativiste
mais peut-être vous en êtes vous rendu
compte dans notre petite exploration du
relativisme on a en fait évoquer deux
relativisme
et maintenant on va distinguer ces deux
relativisme ces deux formes de
relativisme
pour voir s'il est réellement pertinent
de les différencier ou pas
le premier relativisme qu'on a évoqué
c'est le relativisme des valeurs
le relativisme des valeurs c'est le fait
de considérer que les normes que nous
reconnaissons comme juste je parle des
normes morales ou des normes sociales
que ces normes sont relatives à une
société sont relatives à une époque où à
une culture et que donc nos valeurs non
finalement de valeur que celle qu'on
leur donne
autrement dit le relativisme des valeurs
c'est le fait de dire qu'il n'ya pas un
modèle normatif meilleur qu'un autre
qu'il n'y a pas de modèle normatif
supérieur à un autre
et donc que le bien et le mal
juste et l'injuste ne seraient pas des
absolus
le bien et le mal dépend d'abord de
notre conception du bien et du mal
ils dépendent de notre histoire et
dépendent de notre évolution de notre
sensibilité
et partant de là l'idée d'une hiérarchie
des valeurs
apparaît comme un possible
parce que pour juger de la supériorité
ou de l'infériorité d'un système de
valeurs il faut forcément se référer à
des critères qui ne sont pas neutres
prenons un exemple
la liberté
la liberté au sens de liberté
individuelle
il ya des sociétés qui ne considère pas
la liberté individuelle comme un idéal
il y à des sociétés où la liberté n'est
pas perçu comme une valeur fondamentale
nous occidentaux modernes nous
considérons la liberté individuelle
comme une valeur fondamentale comme une
valeur sacrée
parce que notre histoire nous a conduit
à considérer la liberté comme sacrée
parce que nous sommes la nation qui a
décapité son roi
fait la révolution
que c'est sur les décombres de la
monarchie que nous avons construit la
république
est donc temps que la république tiendra
nous célébrerons les valeurs qui ont
fécondé la république
mais c'est logique
c'est presque du tribe
la tribu ganis autour de certains
principes
la liberté
l'égalité le progrès
ces principes constituent la colonne
vertébrale de la tribu
son totem
on se réunit autour du totem
au communient autour du totem
et si quelqu'un vient briser le totem
la tribu implose
la tribu se dissout
donc on protège le totem
on lui rend grâce
on le fétichise
parce qu'il est l'externalisation des
valeurs qui nous rassemblent
mais dans une société où la liberté
n'est pas la valeur fondatrice
par exemple dans une société où c'est la
force qui est une valeur fondatrice
ou dans une société ou c'est le travail
la valeur fondatrice
ou un texte religieux peu importe
c'est le système normatif en vigueur qui
sera le critère d'évaluation des autres
systèmes
encore une fois on évalue toujours à
partir de son système
les sociétés à haut rendement économique
ont intérêt à faire prévaloir le critère
du rendement économique
les sociétés à fort indice de bien-être
ont intérêt à faire valoir le critère du
bien-être
et les sociétés très pieuse ont intérêt
à combattre au nom de dieu
chacun d'eux vittek
chacun d'eux enfin le modèle qui fait de
lui ce qu'il est
et si on ça a une petite dose de
nietzsche
chacun défend le modèle qui garantit ses
intérêts
pas forcément ses intérêts économiques
ces intérêts psychologique
ses intérêts
existentielle
car n'oublions pas c'est tout à l'heure
un système de valeurs
s'engage tout notre rapport au monde
toute notre
10 mt
pour quelqu'un au dessus de tout
l'obéissance à dieu la liberté
individuelle c'est le mal
parce que ce n'est pas la liberté
individuelle qui façonne son rapport à
l'existence
pour quelqu'un qui placent l'égalité
sociale au dessus de tout
l'argent c'est le mal
parce que l'argent c'est un demande
pouvoir
c'est même le seul véritable instrument
de pouvoir
l'instrument de la domination et de la
division
donc les valeurs que vous placer au
dessus de tout et à partir desquels vous
juger les autres valeurs ce sont les
valeurs qui découlent de votre
métaphysique personnel
et le relativisme consiste à dire qu'on
ne peut pas juger la métaphysique de
l'autre
ou plutôt que si on la juge c'est
toujours à partir de notre propre
métaphysique et donc l'autre peut en
faire exactement autant
dire à l'autre ce que tu fais mal
c'est en dire moins sur l'autre que sur
vous même
vous savez c'est comme dans les débats
politiques quand un candidat croit que
pour disqualifier le discours de son
adversaire il suffit de l'attaqué sur
les valeurs
mais enfin les valeurs de l'un ne sont
pas les valeurs de l'autre
croire qu on disqualifie le discours de
quelqu'un en disant qu'il n'est pas
assez humaniste ou qu'il est trop
individualiste
si oublier qu'il y a des gens pour
lesquels l'humanisme n'est pas la valeur
fondamentale
au qu'il ya des gens pour lesquels
l'individualisme est une valeur
fondamentale
donc l'argument des valeurs il pas
parce que ce n'est pas un argument
les valeurs ne sont pas une affaire
d'arguments
elles sont faire de rapport au monde
et donc le relativisme c'est considérer
qu'un humaniste n'a pas raison par
principe contre un anti humaniste
ou qu un individualiste n'a pas raison
par principe contre un socialiste
parce que ce sont justement les
principes derrière lesquels on se range
qui déterminent la manière dont on
évalue les opinions
et c'est ça qu'on résumé dans la célèbre
citation de protagoras l'homme est la
mesure de toute chose
l'homme est la mesure de toute chose ça
veut dire l'homme et à lui même son
propre critères d'évaluation
tout ce que l'homme jugent ils le jugent
d'abord à partir de lui même
partant de là à chacun jugement
à chacun - du
l'origine philosophe activisme c'est la
prise de conscience de l'idée selon
laquelle
une grande partie des choses nous
échappent
des tas de choses nous échappent
l'apparition de la vie nous échappe
la formation on de l'univers nous
échappe
le devenir de chance nous échappe
comme le disait dago race
des dieux je ne puis dire ni s'ils sont
ni s'ils ne sont pas
je ne peux pas le dire parce que pour le
dire il me faudrait en avoir la
certitude
or comment pourrais-je avoir la
certitude de quelque chose dont je n'ai
ni la preuve physique
ni la preuve logique
le dogmatisme c'est ce que combat le
relativisme
parce que le relativisme découle de la
conscience que nos idées sont faibles
nos idées sont faible comparé à ce
qu'elle cherche à atteindre
et c'est là qu'on arrive au deuxième
relativisme ou plutôt à la deuxième
forme du relativisme le relativisme de
la connaissance
et pourquoi ce deuxième relativisme
at-il quelque chose de particulier et
bien parce qu'il nous met en présence
d'un gros problème
le relativisme des valeurs c'est quelque
chose qu'on peut envisager
on peut l'envisager parce qu'on a tous
déjà fait l'expérience de l'altérité des
valeurs
on a tous déjà vu ce soit à l'étranger
ou chez des populations d'origine
étrangère
des coutumes des pratiques des croyances
qui ne sont pas les nôtres
mais qu'on peut comprendre
ou en tout cas dont on admet qu'elle ait
un sens pour ceux qui croient même si
elles n'ont pas pour nous
un sens qui nous échappe
on peut ne pas croire en dieu
mais comprendre que des gens pris
ça ne veut pas dire
cyber qu'ils ont raison
ça veut dire qu'on comprend qu'ils ont
leurs raisons
on peut être
a list et comprendre que des gens
admirent napoléon
parce que même si on n'est pas sensible
à l'esprit de conquête on admet que
certaines personnes puissent l'être
donc sans être relativiste on peut être
respectueux des croyances et des
pratiques de l'autre ça ne veut pas dire
qu'on ait place au même niveau que les
nôtres dans notre hiérarchie personnel
ça veut dire qu'on admet la possibilité
de leur existence
mais dès lors qu'il ne s'agit plus de
valeur mais qui agit de la connaissance
autrement dit dès lors qu'il s'agit de
ce qui est vrai et de ce qui est faux
c'est plus compliqué d'être relativiste
parce que qu'est-ce que ça signifie que
toutes les sont du vrai se valent
ça signifie qu'il n'y a pas de vérité
et s'il n'y a pas de vérité ça veut dire
que tout est à la fois vrai et faux
s'il n'y a pas de vérité
il n'y a pas de ge
il n'y a pas de son
il n'y a pas de torsion de la vérité
et ça ça m'a pas
pourquoi ça marche pas
parce que si je dis qu'un carré est une
figure à quatre côtés et comme répond
que non un carré est une figure à trois
côtés ça veut dire que je devrais
considéré que les deux phrases sont
vraies en même temps
et ça c'est pas possible
c'est pas possible pour des raisons
logiques
or la logique
ne peut pas être relative
la ligne du relativisme
c'est la logique
et c'est là qu'il va art être attentif
la logique ne dépend pas point de vue
la logique ne dépend pas d'eux
objectivité
si aaa est plus grand que b et que b est
plus grand que c'est alors à est plus
grand que c'est c'est comme ça c'est
définitif y'a pas moyen de contourner
donc la logique n'est pas relative
mais ce qui est relatif en revanche
c'est la forme de notre logique
qu'est ce que c'est la forme de notre
logique c'est sa structure
c'est la manière dont elle fonctionne
or notre logique fonctionne sur le
principe de la dualité
c'est une logique binaire
par exemple soit une chose existe soit
elle n'existe pas
il n'ya pas d'entre deux
choses
a à la fois existé et ne pas exister
ça nous paraît très absurde
et pourtant on sait qu'il ya des
situations où la logique binaire ne
fonctionne pas
parce que la réalité n'est pas toujours
binaire
par exemple le principe de l'intrication
quantique
qui a donné lieu à des expériences de
téléportation quantique
c'est justement la preuve que la réalité
se comporte parfois en dépit de la
logique
ou en tout cas en dépit de notre logique
donc certes on ne peut pas parler de la
relativité de la logique au sein d'un
même système logique
puisqu'un système logique contient ses
propres règles et donc ses propres
vérités
mais d'autres systèmes logiques sont
possibles dans lesquelles les règles ne
sont plus les mêmes
et dès lors que la logique n'obéit plus
aux mêmes règles dès lors que la logique
devient elle-même un point de vue parmi
d'autres
paradigmes parmi d'autres et bien à ce
moment là la logique cesse elle aussi
d'être un absolu
la logique vient notre logique
on trouve ça géométrie avec l'âme sur
l'espace à plus de trois dimensions
alors que pour nous trois dimensions
c'est le maximum
tout simplement parce que nous sommes
nous mêmes des êtres en trois dimensions
nous sommes des êtres volumique
et parce que nous sommes des êtres en
trois dimensions et que nous percevons
la réalité en trois dimensions nous
n'imaginons pas un espace qui
contiendrait plus de trois dimensions
et pourtant on peut parfaitement
envisager un espace à quatre dimensions
et je parle bien de dimension physique
non pas le fait que la quatrième
dimension serait le temps
pour les mathématiciens un espace à
quatre dimensions ou à cinq dimensions
ou même à onze dimensions c'est pas un
problème
ça n'a rien d'incohérent
c'est juste un autre référentiel
un autre référentiel qui a ses propres
règles
et donc le relativisme de la
connaissance ce n'est pas tant l'idée
qu'il n'y aurait pas de vérité
aucune vérité scientifique
aurait la même valeur que l'opinion de
monsieur tout le monde
c'est l'idée que de connaissances ne
sont vrai que dans le cadre du
référentiel dont elles proviennent
et qu'un rêve sial humain là pas de
raison particulière
d'être le seul référentiel
potentiellement valable
on peut imaginer un référentiel logique
dans lequel le vrai le faux se
superposent
où se chevauchent
et dans ce référentiel là nos
raisonnements vole en éclats
la difficulté est temps que notre
équipement cognitif nous retient dans
une logique binaire
et donc tout ce qui s'en écartent sera
perçue
de notre point de vue comme n'ayant pas
de sens
le relatif ici c'est la reconnaissance
de la pluralité fondamentale des
conceptions possible du monde
en même temps que le renoncement
à atteindre son sens ultime
je cite
l'idée que l'homme est la mesure de
toute chose permet de s'accommoder d'une
réalité contradictoires son relativisme
remet en question le principe de non
contradiction selon lequel une même
chose ne peut pas en même temps être x
et ne pas être x par exemple si l'homme
est la mesure de toute chose une
personne qui voit une fleur rouge dans
un arbre et une autre personne
daltonienne la voie verte on peut dire
alors que la fleur est à la fois vertes
et rouges de même si une personne croit
que les lapins sont des reptiles et une
autre croix que les lapins ne sont pas
des reptiles alors on peut dire que les
lapins sont à la fois des reptiles et ne
sont pas des reptiles au reste
cette conception légitime l'idée que ce
qui est majoritaire dans l'opinion à une
valeur supérieure en effet si l'on suit
la logique attribua protagoras comme la
réalité dépend de ce que chacun perçoit
ressent et croit le discours de la
majorité discours le plus consensuel est
en même temps le discours le plus vrai
la conception par protagoras de la
vérité tranche avec la conception
traditionnelle qu'il existe une seule
vérité celle d'un discours qui décrit
fidèlement une réalité elle-même unique
et extérieur la vérité des sophistes ton
protagoras est un représentant s'oppose
à celle des philosophes elle est
susceptible de degré et de changements
au gré des fluctuations des croyances et
des émotions des humains il n'y a pas
une seule vérité éternelle mais des
vérités dominante à telle époque et en
tel lieu enfin la doctrine de l'homme
mesure ouvre la voie à une conception
pragmatiste de la vérité selon laquelle
la vérité et ce qui est utile pour
l'homme si l'homme est la mesure de
toute chose et si l'homme mesure toute
chose en fonction de l'utilité que
celles ci peuvent lui apporter alors la
vérité n'est autre que l'utilité
si le relativisme nous encourage à
cesser de vouloir atteindre les grandes
vérités universelles
c'est parce que le relativisme
croit en une grande vérité humaine
l'impossibilité pour l'homme de remonter
au principe ultime
l'impossibilité pour l'homme de trouver
la réponse
à la grande énigme de l'être
ça tu réponds
nous la cherchons par tous les moyens
par la science
par la religion
par l'art
et les réponses bon
ce sont nos réponses
des réponses condamné à rester les
nôtres
nous naviguons entre les expériences
nous éprouvons le monde et ses lois à la
recherche d'une réponse
à la rochelle
de la réponse
celle qui donnera une signification on a
tous à
celles qui à un terme
à nos interrogations
le relativisme n'est pas une défaite
il est
une mise âme l'orgueil
une mise à mort de l'illusion dogmatique
qui nous aveugle d'autant plus
que nous ne la remarquent ont pas
nous voulons des réponses
ont des réponses
des réponses
définitive
absolue
et si nous les trouvons pas
nous les créons
nous les traitons
nous les adoptants
et nous fuit sont par oublier que nous
les avons créé
nous finissons par oublier que ces
réponses
sont nos réponses
mais 6
ont du sens pour nous
6e
ces réponses
qui s'imposent à nous
assumons les
assumons d'être guidés
par des choses
que pour nous
à sion de ne pas être compris
et de ne pas ouah besoin de l'être
assumons de cheminée seul
vers notre absolue
je vous remercie
[Musique]